saluant il a changé de tee-shirt oui je
change de t-shirts quand je veux dans
cette vidéo vous avez vu un deux fois
entre la réponse c'est l'énigme des fois
d'une vidéo à l'autre ses freestyles
niveau t-shirt alors comme tous les
jours pendant 32 jours cet été je vous
donne une énigme et chaque jour je vous
donne la solution de l'énigme de la
veille donc on commence par ça
aujourd'hui si vous n'avez pas vu
l'énigme me dire qu'est ce qu'on fait
exactement il faut aller la voir parce
que là je donne la solution maintenant
alors qu'elle est la led qui vient après
le scb c'est encore un autre
ace après 1h après ça n a pressé un des
1 euro/1 d1t pourquoi parce que ce sont
des premières lettres de 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 etc etc
ça n'avait rien à voir avec la position
de la lettres dans l'alphabet c'est en
fait la première lettre de chacun des
chiffres dans l'ordre ça aurait pu
marcher d'ailleurs avec elle
m mj lundi mardi mercredi jeudi ou avec
les mois de l'année
c'est pas évident à trouver parce qu'il
faut avoir un autre point de vue mais
quand le trou on verra j'ai compris et
peut-être c'est la sensation que ça va
vous donner en trouvant la solution de
l'énigme d'aujourd'hui c'est une
question qu'est ce qui est si fragile au
point de mourir quand on prononce son
nom
je répète qu'est ce qui est si fragile
au point de mourir quand on prononce son
nom
cherchez bien vous aurez la réponse
demain évidemment si vous avez trouvez
vous pouvez être j'ai trouvé dans les
commentaires et laisser un pouce en
l'air les pouces en l'air dans cette
série de vidéos nous sert à savoir le
nombre de personnes qui ont trouvé la
bonne réponse
profitez bien du soleil passer un bel
été et rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
et